Marshall 40 years we rode together I  never got anything right maybe somebody  else ought to be in charge now don't you  go starting on me - all right start  nothing I reckon you're gonna stand tall  are you so mad at Kilauea Josh you were  supposed to watch his back that blonde  girl you don't pay for this Eddie was my  friend I don't know I'm so glad you came  nowhere else happy we've almost won  friend and I don't plan on losing enough  chase and Eddie's killer may bring him  back some [ __ ] killed my partner  I could shoot 50 still like the down  fula see ya now this got a real damn  possible  [Music]  my baby after his mouth this one here in  the back way how can the Frog  [Applause]  just get off vehicle because I'm feeling  a tad bit jumpy  [Music]  you didn't deserve die this way  I'll see him to the jail you'll have  your say before the judge  hand them over first run the muskets  bullets  this isn't the land it once was it's  money  it makes fools a man  you  you